Salut, après un an et-demi de vidéos, de spectacles et d'écriture de livre
j'ai décidé de faire une pause cet été, pour me reposer oui, mais aussi pour
vous préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en septembre. Je vous ai demandé sur Twitter si
vous vouliez quelques facts rapides et divertissants en attendant.
Alors pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous laisse une vidéo rapide et sans prétention
tous les jours pairs à 11h ! On se retrouve à la rentrée et... tout de suite !
Salut, aujourd'hui on se refait une petite énigme. Dans cette énigme il y a un contexte.
Vous allez imaginer 2 youtubers qui ont 3 actions à faire.
Et ça c'est pour remporter un nouveau challenge
qu'aurait mis en place Youtube, imaginons ! Il y a le montage d'une vidéo à faire
sur un ordinateur et il n'y a qu'un seul ordinateur,
il faut également tourner une vidéo et il n'y a qu'une seule caméra,
et il faut également écrire une vidéo et il n'y a qu'un seul carnet avec
un seul stylo pour écrire la vidéo. Chacune de ces tâches, le tournage,
le montage et l'écriture prend exactement 1h
si elle est faite par une seule personne. Le challenge va commencer et ils ont
100 minutes pour réaliser l'ensemble des tâches. 100 minutes
pas une de plus. Ma question est : est-ce que, déjà ils ont une possibilité
de réussir le challenge sans l'aide de personne parce que je vous rappelle
qu'il y a une vidéo à faire et il n'y a qu'une seule caméra, il faut écrire
une vidéo et il n'y a qu'un seul carnet avec un seul stylo,
et il faut monter une vidéo et il n'y a qu'un seul ordinateur. Chacune de ces actions,
si elle est faite par une seule personne, prend 1 heure
et ils ont 100 minutes pour tout faire. Est-ce que c'est possible ?
Si oui, comment ? Cherchez bien. Alors attention, si vous voulez chercher,
n'hésitez pas à quitter la vidéo maintenant et à revenir plus tard, ou à mettre sur pause,
parce que là je ne vais pas tarder à donner la réponse. Et comme toujours pour les
énigmes, essaie, oui toi, de retenir ta main qui a envie
de donner des trucs et des réponses dans les commentaires. Attention !
Réponse dans 3, 2, 1...Maintenant ! Alors la réponse est OUI,
déjà, ils peuvent remporter le challenge. Sinon,
ça ne servirait à rien. Maintenant c'est ''comment'' qui nous intéresse.
Si les 2 youtubers se mettent chacun sur une tâche durant 1 heure,
ils se feront forcement avoir puisqu'à la fin il ne restera plus que 40 minutes,
et comme chaque action ne peut être faite que par un personne,
une seule personne, puisqu'il n'y a qu'un seul ordinateur, qu'une seule caméra
et qu'un seul carnet. Et qu'il faut 60 minutes pour réaliser une action,
ils ne peuvent pas la faire. Mais il y a une alternative qui va leur permettre de même avoir 10 minutes
d'avance avant la fin. Il faut que le premier youtuber commence à faire
une vidéo pendant 30 minutes pendant qu'en simultané, l'autre youtuber
écrit une vidéo pendant 30 minutes. Au bout de ces 30 minutes, le premier
youtuber passe à l'écriture de la vidéo pendant encore 30 minutes,
tandis que le youtuber 2 passe au montage de la
vidéo pendant 30 minutes. Ils font donc ça simultanément pendant 30 minutes.
A la fin de ces 30 minutes, donc on est à 60 minutes, le youtuber 2
qui était en montage passe au tournage pour 30 minutes,
le youtuber 1 qui lui, était en écriture, passe au montage donc pendant
30 minutes aussi également, toujours de manière simultanée. Et la c'est terminé
puisqu'il y aura eut 2 fois 30 minutes au montage, 2 fois 30 minutes à l'écriture
et 2 fois 30 minutes au tournage. Donc ils ont réalisé
toutes les actions en 90 minutes, ils ont gagné. Et bravo
aussi si vous aviez trouvé la bonne réponse. Si ça vous a plu, n'oubliez pas
le petit like, de vous abonner également si c'est pas encore fait.
Je vous rappelle que c'est une vidéo tous les 2 jours cet été jusqu'au 30 août.
C'est le principe de cet été, des vidéos une petit peu plus courtes mais très régulièrement
sur des sujets plus légers. Et donc rendez-vous après
demain, Ciao !